from drought to firestorm for Oklahoma  nature is proving a cruel adversary  tinderbox conditions and high winds  fueling a blaze that's engulfed huge  sways of the Midwestern State very  difficult fire fight to protect the  structures is something that you can't  really get fire trucks to it's all  footwork hand work with some crews the  wild fires broke out on Thursday on a  u.s. army bases gunnery range before  quickly jumping a main highway and  spreading across the countryside an  estimated five thousand acres of  grassland or a light in the resort of  medicine Park dozens of homes and  businesses were ordered to evacuate with  some properties reduced to a cinder  we've lost approximately 10 to 12  structures we haven't lost any labs  staff and guests at this bed and  breakfast were among those forced to  flee scary very scary when they came  through town saying mandatory evacuation  over the loudspeakers it was pretty  nerve-wracking the bed and breakfast  fine